trying to find my new theme song here
bros and oh watch no
that's dumb dude nobody's ever gonna
listen to a song this
is cheesy and lame dude i need something
original
oh what what's this a notification on my
phone
our slash coffeezilla underscore gg
uploaded a new song
let's take a listen my garage my garage
lamborghini lamborghini
[Music]
shut that off shut the shut that shut
that off
let's go to the board how you guys doing
what's up that was made by one of you
that's right on our slash coffeezilla
underscore gg beating out all
other stupid theme songs you could
imagine
go to coffeezilla underscore gg guys
today it's a lazy reddit saturday you
know what that means
we're looking at the memes of the
community last week i asked you to tell
me a time
you were scammed and you guys delivered
let's take a look at that first
we got a lot of these good job guys a
lot of pyramid schemes in there
um this guy was uh got sold on a
c plus learning kit this guy lost sixty
thousand dollars i was organizing a
dance festival
in country that shall not be named lost
over 60 thousand dollars how not knowing
the local way of doing business and
applying the canadian way
of organizing events in a place that's
built on corruption
dude why does that have no upvotes
that's crazy got scammed by a private
investigator who took an upfront
fee and did nothing it was only when i
told my mom she said you didn't pay them
first
right yeah it's a common scam
years later i ended up being my own
internet detect
hey i feel like this is not a real story
i became a real internet detective i
could see the amount of effort the same
job required
just how badly i was conned at the time
yeah guys these j
look i have the hardest job in the world
i'm gonna be real with you guys
this is tough but i do i remember i
joined an mlm called primerica
oh yeah this is real had no idea about
scams or anything like that my friend
introduced me i got sold by the skimmer
motivational speeches
etc guys don't do this they wanted me to
go door-to-door service selling
insurance and vacuum cleaners how did
those things fix
ma'am you're gonna need the the vacuum
suck 5000 and while you're at it can i
sell you on some life insurance
because these things are deadly i'm
gonna have to go ahead and award the
primerica
mlm and i think you guys will all agree
going door-to-door selling insurance and
vacuum cleaners
um that's about as bad as it gets
private message wow your life sucks
give congratulations internet points
internet points thanks for playing
now we're moving on from the competition
to the memes guys this
is what you really came for and this is
what y'all are good at honestly i don't
even know why we do a challenge y'all
no legends at these memes okay traders
on tick tock
be like hello there have you heard of
the good news of our
lord and savior at the pump respect the
pump look i know people are saying ivan
on tech or whatever is legit dude it's a
good meme
just accept the meme into your life
accept the pump and accept the meme
into your life please guys please
stephen after he finished the dim mac
course
oh my gosh what is this dude this is a
good
oh this is the best deep fake i've ever
seen look at that
oh wait it has sound dude i was missing
the sound this should get even better
[Music]
yes
honestly though how'd you get real
footage of me i i don't even know that
that's
i mean that just looks like a gym
training session to be quite
quite honest dan lok the true sifu here
dropping poverty ending wisdom bars dude
does dan lok rap now
money is the root of all evil no
lack of money is the root of all evil
lacks of money is the root of all evil
that lack of money is the root of all
these flags
[Music]
[Music]
how do y'all have time to do this i'm
shocked how
why is anyone watching me dude this
guy's crushing it dan lok money wisdom
when amish becomes a meditation guru and
runs an
ashram from the future oh guys if you
guys don't know the drip
podcast is alive and well over on the
drip channel link that right there
uh let's see what this is about if you
don't know we praise the algorithm all
the time
[Music]
this is true it's all true this is i
want to believe that this is actually
written directed
sang by amish he does like communism he
loves it
[Music]
don't send this to amish whatever you
guys do this is going gonna go way too
sad
i swear dude next one what time is it
and then they link to
a goop product called the pelvic clock
exercise device only
84 dollars as you can see what are you
supposed to do with it
what is it like a little piece of
plastic that's all it is that's 84
dude gwyneth paltrow is the real fake
guru what the
hell is going on who would buy that this
lady's running the real racket dude what
am i focused on i'm focused on all these
baby gurus
and gwyneth paltrow is just crushing the
game
coffeezilla after he's destroyed all the
fake groups and you finally sell his own
course with zero competition if i ever
sell a course
it's the ultimate test if you guys have
learned your lesson from all my videos
i'm not going to sell the course
let you know if i sell a course guys i
fully expect
none of you to buy it no sales i want to
be
the one guru who can promise extreme
riches and nobody falls for it the sad
thing is i think
people actually would um but i'd like to
hope
not coffee casually walking into a fake
guru invested youtube to do some cleanup
hey i would never stop
listen i just want you guys to be aware
of the scam i would never do i'm a
peaceful guy
dude i'm a lover when you're a
coffeezilla student
i don't have students guys guru i can
show you how to get rich trading
me really guru yeah just pay me fifteen
hundred dollars
all right then keep your secrets
oh why did you have to use frodo baggins
though
i feel like there's some kind of uh an
innuendo here that i don't appreciate
quite frankly swag academy stonk
swag yolo now they will think i'm cool
dude i've got swag now guys
don't ever forget it you can never say i
don't have swag i literally graduated
from the academy
so please youtube can be brutal for
scammers when new emerging scammers sees
himself in the coffees of the thumbnail
dude you know what's weird is that like
it doesn't feel
you know we we've grown a lot in the
past year
and it feels like you know i feel like
we're just still the same channel
but it's wild to think we have any kind
of influence and that's all thanks to
you guys so
shout out to all the copies of
underscore gg subreddit members shout
out to everybody subscribe
um you guys are literally what's helping
regulate this industry
um because without your views like
there'd be no impact right next meme
thanks for effing up my retargeted ads
coffee ps
and withdrawing from harvard tomorrow
may have stumbled upon the greatest
opportunity of her era okay i think i
know where this is going
of course dude caleb maddox new case
study the three secrets we used to get
3 800 high ticket clients in 90 days
come on caleb dude just get out of this
industry man this is not the place
like right like are you really helping
people are you just taking
are you just kind of rent seeking off of
people who want to be successful and
you're rent seeking and pretending like
you have the answers
i don't know that kind of pisses me off
all right last meme
interesting advert i got on the local
newspaper website
okay
the all-time memer dude i think this is
one of the great coffeezilla memes of
all time i don't know if anyone's gonna
top him
this is my own urine bookies make brian
one okay we've already talked about this
this is fake
stuff you can just pump these up guys he
literally has no chance of winning don't
buy into it
anyways guys i think that's it for now
uh
thanks for watching guys next week got
an important new competition for you i
realized
that what you guys on the coffee
solution are really good at
is making memes it's doing that so
that's what we're gonna do a competition
on
highest upvoted meme it's not one
platinum
but also the legendary seal of approval
two very coveted awards and you win them
if you have the highest upvoted meme by
the end
of the week the competition begins
right now thank you for watching i hope
you enjoyed
and i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
you